das Industrieland Deutschland ist droht
in dieser Energiekrise zum
Industriemuseum zu werden ja das sagt
einer der wichtigsten Industriebosse
Sätze bei dem es einem Wirklichkeit den
Rücken runterläuft ein Satz von Markus
Steilmann hören wir rein dem Chef des
Verbands der Chemieindustrie
das Ausbauziel ist im Moment irgendwo
zwischen 600 und 800 Terawattstunden bis
2030 wenn ich das erreichen möchte
bräuchte ich jeden Tag 10
Windkraftanlagen eine Windkraftanlage
braucht 4000 Tonnen Stahl das ist ein
halber Eiffelturm das heißt fünf
Eiffeltürme jeden Tag und das für den
nächsten acht Jahre 365 Tage im Jahr das
möchte ich mal sehen wie wir das auf dem
weg kriegen da müssen wir hin weil
ansonsten wird alles was wir hier heute
diskutieren Makulatur bleiben und
Deutschland wird sich von einer
Industrienation in ein Industriemuseum
verwandeln und zwar schneller als wir
uns das vorstellen können von der
Industrienation zu einem Industriemuseum
das sind knallharte Worte von einem von
Deutschlands wichtigsten Industrie
Wirtschaftsbossen und wir sprechen mit
einem anderen nämlich mit Ludwig moering
dem Chef des großen gasverbandes in
Deutschland grüß Dich herzlich einmal
ganz kurz zu dem Satz des Kollegen vom
Industrieland von der Industrienation
zum Industriemuseum übertreibter oder
stimmt ich glaube hier hat er gerade
gesprochen von der von den Anforderungen
der Transformation unserer unserer
Energielandschaft hin von den
konventionellen Energien zu zu den zu
den erneuerbaren Energien und welche
großen Anforderungen das sind die den
Zahlen ist nicht hinzuzufügen parallel
dazu müssen wir feststellen dass wir
eben aktuell auch noch
Energiepreise haben die natürlich die
von ihm angesprochenen Stahlpreise
weiter in die Höhe treiben werden also
dass die die Anforderungen die wir jetzt
haben an den an den Umbau der
legendschaft sind noch mal massiv
gestiegen sie eine Gasthäuser
angesprochen bei vielen trudeln jetzt
die Rechnungen ein viele schon in
Geldbeutel und fragen sich wie sollen
wir das bezahlen da muss doch irgendeine
Lösung her was können wir tun in welchen
Winter steuern wir da rein wir bewerten
Sie das wie wird dieser Winter ja also
wir stellen ja alle fest dass quer durch
die Politik ob es im Bund ist ob es in
den Ländern ist es ist überall
angekommen hier muss den Menschen im
Land ob es nun die Haushalte sind ob es
Mittelstand ist ob es die
Industrieunternehmen sind
den muss geholfen werden nicht also die
die Großhandelspreise für Erdgas sind
von von alten Zeiten 20 Euro die
Megawattstunde auf auf 150 und mehr
geschrieben das bedeutet von 20
Milliarden bezogen auf den ganzen Markt
auf 150 Milliarden Euro und mehr das und
das nur der Gasmarkt im Strommarkt gilt
ähnlich ist das auszugleichen wird Start
an seine Grenzen bringen aber umso
wichtiger ist ja das Bund und Länder wir
haben es gestern alle gehört an dem
Thema dran sind aber man sieht schnell
viel Geld ausgegeben ja die haben
beschlossen dass sie viel Geld ausgeben
wollen haben sie aber nicht geeinigt
wäre es tun soll da haben sehr lange
dummen rätselt und sind quasi ohne
Einigung auseinandergegangen aber
schauen wir noch mal auf die wahnsinnig
hohen Gaspreise gehen Sie davon aus dass
jetzt sagen wir mal nach Dezember nach
Januar Februar das irgendwann wieder
runter geht mit den Preisen
der Erdgasmarkt ist ein Weltmarkt wie
wir leben gerade in einer
knappheitssituation die den Weltmarkt
also insbesondere Europa und und Asien
betroffen hat Amerika oder Nordamerika
führte ein Eigenleben
solange keine großen neuen Gasmengen
dazukommen müssen wir leider davon
ausgehen dass wir Preise sehen die im
Bereich dessen sind was wir jetzt seit
seit Monaten leider am Markt zur
Kenntnis nehmen dann los mehr Gas wo
soll es herkommen mehr Gas schnell muss
ja die Aussage sein mehr Gas schnell
wird es wird es nicht geben können dass
sie die ganz harte Wahrheit darum sind
ja auch die die Ansätze zu sagen wir
müssen Gas sparen wir müssen raus aus
der Gas Verstromung an die an die die
das petitium an die Bürger weniger
weniger gastronen alles richtig das
Problem ist das große Thema nämlich
diese riesigen Mengen russischen Gases
für Europa als Ganzes zu ersetzen wird
in dieser Geschwindigkeit nicht nicht
gelingen können große neue Projekte
werden ein mehrjährigen follow haben das
heißt wir können das gar nicht
entspannen und sagen irgendwann kommt
der Frühling und dann wird's schon
wieder besser ihre einschätz danach wird
uns dieses Thema auch was unseren
eigenen Geldbeutel betrifft noch wie
lange begleiten
erstmal ist wichtig und da haben wir
große Fortschritte gemacht dass genügend
erdgasmoleküle da sind das zweite ist
können wir diese Moleküle auch bezahlen
und da müssen wir leider befürchten dass
wir auf jeden Fall durchs nächste Jahr
gehen meine persönliche Sorge ist dass
wir auch nach dem Winter 23 24 an der an
der Stelle der Preise mit Sicherheit
keine keine Entwarnung geben können es
wird weiterhin teuer sein wie teuer das
ist die bekannte Frage die die keiner so
beantworten kann sagt leider Ludwig
Möhring der Chef des großen deutschen
gasverbandes bvag ich danke Ihnen für
den Besuch hier bei herzlichen
[Musik]